A lot of times we think about the way
that we do business,
it kind of developed countries
that we're like, well, you know,
we're going to do it in an efficient way.
We'll just jump on a call
and kind of get things done.
Well, that's not
typically how things work
in a lot of other countries in the region
and you kind of need to be sensitive
to all of these nuances
if you want to actually be successful.
Ivan Jakovljevic,
thank you so much for joining me.
How are you?
I'm very good, thank you.
Good to be here with you in Dubai.
It's wonderful to be here in Dubai.
So, we have a whole new set of you know,
I've been doing this
over Zoom for 250 episodes.
And done one episode in person.
This is my second one.
And I'm honored to do it
with you here in Dubai.
Thank you for joining me.
Absolutely.
Great to have you here.
Ivan, we are in
the beautiful Emirates Tower.
I don't think
that we can really see it here,
but I'm just going to show it anyway.
The incredible view of Dubai,
really a phenomenal place of innovation.
I've been shocked and blown away
by what's happening in this place.
Ivan, how did you get to Dubai?
Because you've done
Stanford Business School.
You're originally from Serbia.
You've spent many years in Google.
How do you end up helping run investments
and portfolio companies in Dubai?
Short answer, by chance, obviously.
Right?
So, the story is as follows.
I'm originally from Serbia,
as you mentioned.
So, I moved to the states to do Stanford
Graduate School of Business.
That was back in 2006.
After graduating,
I joined the consulting firm
and moved to the city of San Francisco.
And back in the day,
my thinking was essentially like,
kind of follow my American dream, right?
All I have to do is kind of you know,
have a couple of kids,
two and a half kids,
to be more precise,
white picket fence, a dog,
and I should be all set, right?
Except that somehow life worked out.
So, after a couple of years in consulting
in 2008, you know,
there was the global financial crisis
and markets kind of started to rumble
a little bit.
And the firm that I was with at the time,
they were basically looking,
they had a booming
and thriving business here
in the Middle East.
They were looking for people
within the system
to kind of move temporarily
to the Middle East
to kind of help them essentially deliver
on all the projects
that they were able to sell.
Right.
So, you know, before I knew it,
I was basically like, you know,
what's the worst thing
that could possibly happen.
I have never been
to the Middle East before, right?
The only thing I knew
about the Middle East
was kind of from six o'clock news.
And that was never a good thing.
Never a good thing.
But I've been thinking like, you know,
it's like the land of eternal sun,
go there, go for a couple of years,
you know, make some tax free money,
repay my student loans,
and before I knew it,
I was going to be back home.
Right?
Or that's at least what I thought.
That was 2008,
fast forward to 12 and a half years.
I guess, you know,
life is temporary as it is,
but it turned out to be
a little bit more temporary than
the original two years idea.
Unbelievable.
So, you joined Google, right?
You spend quite a long time with Google,
helping them expand their market
and grow into
Middle East North African markets.
What is that like?
What does that responsibility entail?
What are some of the biggest challenges
that you've had along that journey?
Yes, one of the things that people
don't necessarily, not understand,
but like comprehend, right,
is we talk about MENA,
which is the Middle East
and North Africa region,
a lot of people kind of talk about it
as kind of a region
which is relatively uniform.
But in reality,
it's anywhere between 19 and 21 countries
depending on the day
and depending on who does the counting,
which are actually very, very different.
So, we sit here in the Gulf
in the emirates of Dubai,
which is part of the
United Arab Emirates,
one of the richest
countries in the world.
For all intents and purposes,
actually a very, very developed country.
But another country in MENA is
it's Egypt, right?
More than 100 million people.
But it's actually kind of more
in the range of developing countries
as opposed to kind of developed countries
and everything that kind
of comes with it.
Kind of from the level of sophistication
and maturity of the markets to the level
if we are talking about digital economy,
you know, the penetration
of mobile phone, Internet, payment,
payment cards and so on and so forth.
It's a very, very diverse region
that actually needs a lot
of different recipes,
if you will, to kind to be,
"flexible business".
So, that was my role
when I joined Google.
So, we were actually
very well established here in the UAE,
but we didn't have
a very, very meaningful footprint
in the rest of the region, right?
So, when I started doing my
regional head of new markets,
I went segue being head.
Basically my assignment was essentially
to kind of bring everything
that we were able
to build here in the UAE
and to kind of take it further out
into the rest of the region.
And that I mean, at the end,
you have the responsibility
of looking at both the emerging markets,
but also at the developed markets
and playing all these different hats.
Because for every region,
it's not just about
the penetration of the technology,
but it's also about the culture.
And it's about how much do they trust
the payment system,
how much do they trust
digital e-commerce.
And there's a lot of different subtleties
that you really have
to take into account.
Even to the extent I think, covid
is kind of an interesting.
And we're probably
going to talk about that a little bit.
But even in terms of
how you do business, right?
Like in some parts of the region,
some countries in the region, for them,
the working culture
is much more face to face oriented.
There is no way for you
to do business unless
you have kind of first established
a relationship.
Unless you have actually gone
a small chitchat and so on,
unless you have gone
and kind of had coffee with them.
Yeah.
And so on and so forth.
So, a lot of times we think about
the way that we do business
in kind of develop countries that we're
like, well, you know,
we're going to an efficient way.
We'll just jump on a call
and kind of get things done.
Well, that's not typically
how things work in
a lot of other countries in the region.
You kind of need to be sensitive
to all of these nuances
if you want to actually be successful.
100%.
I'm used to the fast paced modeling
in San Francisco.
If I'm getting 15 minutes with somebody
from [--]
and I have those first three minutes
to make the impression.
Here one of the first things they told me
when I came to Dubai, they said,
"Michael, before you mention anything
that has to do with technology,
with investments, whatever,
sit down, have a chat, have a coffee,
invest the time in the relationship,
otherwise, nobody wants to do business."
It's a very different mentality.
Do most people fail that
or do most people understand
and make that quick adaptation?
Because the world is getting globalized,
right?
Right now, it still feels
a little bit fragmented
just by the shock factor
that I've exhibited coming here.
But if I'm looking five, 10 years,
even with the normalization with Israel,
things are going to become more connected.
So, how do you expect people are going
to adapt this more business mindset
within two sides?
Yes. So, Dubai is great,
I think in this regard.
And again, I don't know how well known
that is outside of kind of this
this more narrow region.
But Dubai is like a true melting pot,
right?
It's like, 190 nationalities.
If you think about the population
segmentation, if you will,
again, I don't know
how many people know that,
but out of three million people in Dubai,
less than 10% are the UAE nationals.
10%?
Less than 10% are UAE nationals, right.
Wow.
So, if you think about the likelihood
of you actually bumping into somebody
who's kind of from another country
is like nine out of 10.
And in all likelihood,
they're going to be
from the subcontinent,
they're going to be from Southeast Asia,
they're going to be from Europe or
the UK, less so from the US
and Latin America.
Just kind of from
a geographic distance point of view.
But I think the fact
that it's a melting pot
actually kind of gives rise
to this kind of
being kind of attuned, if you will,
by the kind of more sensitive to the fact
that a person sitting across from you
in a business meeting
is not going to be like you
kind of from a cultural point of view.
So, you may not necessarily
understand their culture,
but you're going to be naturally
more attuned to kind of understand
that it's different from yours.
Right?
And to kind of
give them the benefit of the doubt,
unnecessarily jump to conclusions,
kind of get out of your way,
kind of trying to basically kind of get
get to learn a little bit more about,
you know, how to be effective,
how to establish those relationships,
how to build them,
how to get results, right
at the end of the day.
How do you explain
what we're seeing here?
How does it happen,
as soon as I get to Dubai
and seeing these crazy towers,
people seem to be very happy,
very low crime rate,
you know, what's happening here?
Why is Dubai this crazy melting pot
and why do we have this?
Well, I think the Dubai,
the whole story of Dubai
is really about, and you know,
the way to think about Dubai
is not even related to the MENA region.
It's the way to think about it
is kind of the headquarters of that hub,
if you will, of a very,
very broad region,
which actually comprises
almost two billion people.
And the way that they've kind of set up
and actually kind of started
from the logistics.
So, before Dubai was what it was in 1971,
they've built what is to become
one of the largest ports in the world,
which is DP World in Jebel Ali
which is like
20 miles down the road, right.
And at that time,
there was literally nothing.
I mean, the Dubai, it was more like
a fishing village with like
50 thousand people.
But it was a vision to say that
from a geographic point of view,
it is a hub that is kind of logistically
and distance wise within
a seven to eight hour flight radius,
to more than two billion people.
So, it's a good place to put a port.
And it turned out to be the case.
It's a good place
to actually put an airport in
like an international airport.
And today, Dubai International Airport
is actually the largest
international airport in the world.
Actually.
You've probably heard
about Emirates Airlines.
It's the biggest international airline
in the world in terms
of the number of connections,
in terms of number of people.
They're kind of transporting,
hopping back and forth.
So, think of Dubai as a hub.
So, if you then think about
that broader region that Dubai,
the Dubai covers as a hub,
you have places like India,
you have places like Saudi Arabia,
places like Dubai or places like,
you know, southeast in the south
and east to Eastern Europe,
even to CIS countries, right,
all kind of somewhat naturally gravitated
towards a place
that has established itself
as not only a logistics hub,
but also a hub that it is very convenient
and very safe to do business in.
Right?
From the kind of safety and security
perspective,
but also kind of from a regulation
because they put in a lot of
kind of a very
sort of regulatory framework around,
you know, just kind of allowing it
to do business
with the rest of the region.
Unbelievable.
And so, you have a place
of three million people,
90% of them are not even local,
and it's become the hub of the region
that encompasses two billion people.
That's right.
That's just unbelievable.
I don't think that not even myself
or many of my friends I have are actually
understanding what's happening here.
What's going to happen in the future?
If you look at this,
if you look at this whole region, MENA,
the world with Dubai as a hub,
what's going to happen
20 years down the line?
Because the world
is becoming more and more globalized.
I've just experienced it now
because the two nations are normalized.
But what's going to happen
in the future, do you think?
Well, it's anyone's guess right,
at the end of the day.
But I think the vision,
and we're talking about
the pre-covid world,
I think it remains to be seen
what kind of adventures
that the covid are going to throw into,
everything is happening.
But the whole underlying idea
is that probably like,
you know, from this
kind of a grand vision perspective,
we're probably not even like 30% there.
Really?
So, you know, again,
like the emerging markets
are the ones that are
kind of up and coming.
Right?
And we can provide them with talent,
technology,
financial and regulatory framework.
What London and New York have
for the rest of the world,
Dubai aspires to be for
this kind of part of the world
in between Hong Kong and London.
So, all of these things,
I think they've just scratched
the surface of.
If you think about
what is happening in Africa, for example,
which is projected to have more than one,
one and a half billion people, right,
all kind of emerging from poverty
and at some point,
if these economies
kind of start picking up,
Dubai is perfectly positioned
to actually kind of leverage
and kind of profit to all of that.
So, I think the vision still stands.
Again, covid and financial crisis,
they're kind of throwing
a couple of wrenches.
But if you think about the macro trends,
and if those macro trends continue,
I think Dubai is very well-positioned
to benefit from that.
That's interesting.
And I know that you have to go to,
you have a hard stop soon.
But I have to understand a little bit
about the tech ecosystem
with investments.
So, right now, you're leading
chief development officer,
part of STV Saudi.
Technology Ventures, yeah.
Saudi Technology Ventures.
So, you are investing
all across the Middle East
and North Africa.
Give me a little bit of an overview.
Because I know
Silicon Valley pretty well,
I know the United States
and I know Tel Aviv.
I don't know this region.
What's happening here
in terms of technology?
And how does it fare
in comparison to more
of the Western world
on what's happening there?
Yeah. So, listen, the market here
in kind of from a startup point of view
is super nascent, right?
So, I'll give you
just one way to think about it, right.
In terms of the overall amount
of venture funding,
US probably stands at around
100 billion, give or take.
Right?
Places like India are at around
10 to 12 billion, give or take a year.
We are probably hitting our
one billion mark over this year.
So, kind of from
an order of magnitude perspective,
it's still super small
and very, very nascent.
And there are
a number of reasons for that.
I think one of the big reasons for that
is that the economies here,
historically were essentially driven
by large organizations, right?
By the extraction of hydrocarbons,
obviously large companies in the world.
Saudi Aramco is kind of
the oil company
that extracts oil from the ground
and so on and so forth.
A lot of things here
also from an economic point of view
are driven by trade,
which is dominated
by the large family
of conglomerates and all that.
So, if you think about SME or kind of
this whole kind of sentiment around,
starting from the ground up
and having this
kind of a entrepreneurial mindset,
if you will, in kind of making it big
in the world,
it wasn't necessarily
at present, the best here, right?
The regulations
were not supporting it either.
The culture was not supporting it either.
You know, we kind of take for granted
this whole kind of start fail fast,
but then kind of were the scars
of that failure
is kind of a learning experience
and kind of something
that you are proud of, right?
Here in this region,
failure was associated,
there was kind of a negative
connotation to it, right?
So, from a cultural point of view,
regulatory point of view,
economic point of view,
it wasn't a place where, you know,
startups or the kind of
the emergent kind of ecosystem economy
would thrive.
All of this is changing
and all of this
is changing super, super fast.
Right?
So, again, I've told you about
the one billion dollar mark
in venture funding,
but it's actually kind of
on the back of 50 million
that was invested only five years ago.
So, it's literally kind of an,
it's getting kind of exponential growth.
And the reason for me to actually move
from Google to a place like STV,
with all the branding differences
and obviously kind of the safety
and all the other differences
is kind of looking at that opportunity
as super nascent opportunity.
Right?
Essentially, I was telling myself was,
you know, do I want to be there
not only to witness it,
but potentially participate in it
and enable it?
And the clear answer is yes.
And basically,
I told myself I was probably too late
to do that in the Silicon Valley
back in 2006.
But I think I'm probably
not too late here.
Because it's just starting.
I wanted to kind of make
a good use of that.
See the exponential curve.
Ivan, I know we have to go.
And this is a,
I'm keeping you very late.
But thank you so, so much
for joining me on this show.
It's really wonderful.
And I'm so excited to share this
with my friends, with my family.
And I already learned so much.
Ivan, before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most difficult question,
which I didn't prepare you for.
So, I'm sorry, but I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
or anybody at STV or in MENA region
would describe Ivan as.
Interesting.
Father.
Yeah.
I'm a father of three.
Three boys that I'm very proud of.
You wanted two and a half.
So, one of them--
I wanted two and a half,
I really wasn't sure
if I would have ended up on
on one side or the other.
I think the second one is passionate.
Passionate about helping people,
passionate about educating people,
passionate about growing people.
And the third one would be,
it's kind of related to the first one,
but it's family, really.
And not only my immediate family,
but also my broader family as well.
I love it.
Ivan, Thank you so much.
Elbow bump.
Say hi to everyone
at Stanford for me, please.
Will do, thank you.